[Music]
chris joins us up next in los angeles
chris welcome to the ramsay show
hi george thanks for having me yeah
absolutely what's going on
uh yeah so the short of it is um i just
graduated medical school i'm 28 years
old um and i uh luckily i'm not carrying
any debt
anymore and
let's go yeah thanks
thank you appreciate that um but yeah so
my i'm about to start residency training
in july and my family as a graduation
gift essentially is giving me forty
forty thousand dollars um just to kind
of get my
uh get me started um so i can you know
hit the ground running and i have about
ten thousand dollars my own money saved
uh and i'm just calling just to see um
you know what your opinion what your
opinion is on what i can do with it uh
to kind of maximize you know my savings
or my investments and retirements you
know anything like that because i've
been in school for forever and i
don't really um i'm kind of new to this
whole
finance thing that's awesome man thanks
for joining our crazy crew here so let
me recap here you just graduated med
school completely debt free and you have
ten thousand dollars saved in the bank
yes you are a unicorn my friend how did
you get through med school debt free no
wrong answers
uh so it's a combination of a bunch of
scholarships um and family help
awesome
fantastic news man
so you got 40k here and you're going
what is my next goal how much are you
making in residency
i'll be making 57 000 uh pre-tax which i
calculated out to be around 40k
take-home per year oh i love how nerdy
you are this makes me happy
okay so you got 40 000 take home and you
have 40 000 that'll be a lump sum that
you can do whatever you want with what
is your next goal for chris are you
going to be renting somewhere
yes uh so i will be renting um so i'm
moving to a new city so i i'm renting
for now um
not really thinking about buying a house
uh
that's my current salary i guess sure
yeah you don't need to rush into that do
you have a car do you need a car
i will need a car um because my car uh
will be staying here with my family um
and i'm gonna need to use some of that
40 000 to
help purchase a car
so what i would do i think you your next
step would be a fully funded emergency
fund you don't quite know your expenses
yet but i imagine it's going to be a
little more than ten thousand dollars
for three to six months of
expenses actually so um funny enough is
that for the last uh four years in med
school my um i've actually been
tracking my expenses as you mentioned
i'm very nerdy so i literally have like
a spreadsheet going with all of my um
all my you know expenses and everything
i actually tried to kind of get a better
idea of how i budgeted out and i
actually spend about or with rent and
everything and renting food and
everything i my monthly expense is
around
24 to 2700 per month awesome now you're
going to have a new rent that'll come
into play right
that's actually i that's 24 to 2700 is
actually including the new rent that i'm
i just uh signed the lease for okay so
that adds up to about 16 grand so let's
call it 15 grand as a fully funded
emergency fund for you does that sound
good
yeah yeah so let's take five of the 40
you're getting and add it to your
savings that becomes your emergency fund
we're not touching that unless it's an
actual emergency urgent necessary
unexpected so the rest of the 35 sounds
like you need a car
yeah so let's get a reasonable used car
we don't need anything fancy here and if
i'm you i'm probably not spending you
know more than 15 grand
to do that does that sound reasonable
actually yeah that's perfect i've
actually been looking at used cars i'm
looking at around like you know 10 to 15
is kind of what i'm what i'm looking to
spend on a car wonderful so that then
leaves you with an with 20 grand left
and i want you investing 15 of your
income your future income into
retirement so i'm guessing residency you
have a retirement option there 401k
something like that
yes i believe my hospital is gonna
match uh four percent i think is what i
read awesome so i would invest 15 if
they've got good options there if
there's a roth 401k option i'm an even
bigger fan of that that'll use after-tax
dollars it'll grow tax-free so invest 15
of your income that's outside of the
match they're gonna match four percent
you still invest 15 of your income there
and with that 20 000 sitting there in
savings i think your next goal would be
to keep stacking up money and so that
eventually you'll have a nice big down
payment to put down on your first house
okay
okay so
uh
5k added to my 10k as an emergency fund
correct um around 15 nothing more than
15 000 for a nice used car
um fifteen percent of my
uh going like moving forward income into
the 401k raw 401k if i can
um
uh and then the rest of it just kind of
hold on to and kind of keep building it
up until i can put a nice down payment
you nailed it man i love dude you're
already my best friend today
i want you to be my doctor
this is the kind of guy you want in this
profession
that's awesome man your family really
sets you up so well i'm proud of your
you uh you're a sharp young dude and
your family it definitely left a legacy
thank you i appreciate that awesome i
guess one more question
on that would be like so um in terms of
kind of just keeping the money in as
like a savings uh so would you not would
you recommend or not like kind of taking
some of that money and starting to
invest it into like you know mutual
funds or etfs or anything like that
if you want if this is a longer time
horizon you're going hey i know for sure
i'm not getting in a house in the next
three to five years i'm okay with you
parking that in index funds mutual funds
to grow
while you save up
but at this rate and how long are you in
residency for
three years okay so i think it'd be i'd
be a cool goal personally to go hey at
the end of residency what if i had
enough to put down on a house with my
newly found income that you'll have
which i assume is going to be high six
figures
yeah
so i love this plan maybe you wait a
year once you have that new income
you'll be able to stack up a lot of
money really fast so in four years
you uh you put that money down on a
house maybe you could put 40 50 down who
knows
right okay i love this man i'm proud of
you dude i'm gonna send you a copy of my
favorite book that changed my life the
total money makeover hang on austin's
gonna pick up and we will send you a
copy of that to encourage you along the
journey